good morning John earlier this week
matthew inman the oatmeal posted a comic
about how to get likes on facebook and
one of the things that he's suggested
doing was to create a sing-along video
explaining how to properly load a
dishwasher and so oh this is how you
load a dishwasher this is how you load a
dishwasher GE frigidaire Bosch or world
floor any Ghana dishwasher well I like
to put my cutlery in the basket facing
down so my hands never touch the parts
that go inside mouths but others folks
with cleaner hands put them facing the
other way the Jets of water catch them
better with their spray yo with this tag
you load a dishwasher this is how you
load a dishwasher GE Frigidaire washer
whirlpool or any Ghana dishwasher oh
please make sure to check and see if
it's dishwasher safe because you don't
want tougher wear melting to your plates
and remember two straight bumps of cake
dog cheese and fat and always check to
make sure that you don't wash your cat
so this diode that is washer this diode
and this washer ge rich decoupage or
apple or any Ghana dishwasher
Oh heavy things go wrong the bottom and
the light things on top to save water
and energy please fill that sire up and
once you've got everything in its proper
place
it's the detergent push the button with
your face the Sun is gigantic with a
diameter more than 400 times that of the
moon however when you're standing on
earth the Sun in the moon appear to be
roughly the same size the reason for
this is that the Sun is 400 times more
distant from the earth than the moon and
thus appears 400 times smaller is this
just a coincidence
yes very just a good day here at Han
Krieg headquarters I've got a Hank green
shirt on and a Hank Reed's drawing that
I've had something like 2008 and I don't
think I've ever put it on my wall Neal
McMillan thank you for that I'm wearing
this today though because it's one of my
favorite shirts that I ever designed and
it's on sale for $5 off at dftba.com oh
ah that's better feel way less salary
now recently a slew of teenagers didn't
know that the Titanic was a real thing
they just thought it was a movie and yes
when I read these things I feel the same
way as you where I'm just shocked I'm
like what I'm thinking the thing about
like the American education system but
really really there are a lot of things
that twelve year olds aren't being
taught in American schools and the
sinking of the Titanic is not at the top
of my list of addition do they know what
the Battle of Hastings was or like why
the Magna Carta was important probably
not so my immediate question is why is
it that the Titanic things the thing we
care about a lot here's why I think
because the Signum of the Titanic is in
history toss it's still cultural memory
it's just one of those things that
everybody should know but it turns out
that 20 of the 100 million active users
on Twitter did not know that initially
this is shocking to us because we as
humans think that there is a shared
cultural memory that we can count on
everyone knowing but if you think about
it for a couple of seconds it becomes
clear to Howard
greenly unsurprising and really is guess
what we're not all born knowing
everything pretending like those twenty
people are idiots because they like
lived a different life than I did
doesn't serve any purpose except to like
maybe make me feel superior make them
feel horrible and also make me you know
have a little bit less faith in humanity
all those things are bad John that's all
for today I imagine that was enough I'll
see you on Tuesday